hello and welcome to the gas tutorial
this is paralyzing scientific Python
with desk my name is Jim Crist this is
David Mertz
we are both employees of continuum
analytics makers of anaconda and we're
going to be talking about douse a so the
setup for this is super easy you need to
go to that URL and click the big blue
button and that is it and this is going
to drop you into a notebook environment
with a cluster set up behind it and
everything should just work yeah sorry
hang on hang on
there we go
when you get to a notebook password at
PyCon 2017 this was recently used for
PyCon and we didn't change the password
so
by a show of hands how many people have
the notebook environment already up how
many people are having issues okay yeah
okay does anyone still need this URL or
can I move on
okay
how many people meet the Wi-Fi password
is it not redirecting it's getting the
connections not secure thing
Oh which is I think it have the
interaction with the local network but
I'm not quite sure
oh you're missing that do you have the
information to connect to the Wi-Fi
for those of you that are stuck at the
spinning up cluster page it might just
take a couple minutes or so for everyone
to get spun up alright one last time by
a show of hands who is still waiting on
getting to the notebook environment just
a handful is everyone who sees that I'm
seeing the waiting for clustered at it
or at least at that point let's hope
google kubernetes spins Isaac yeah yeah
spins i but enough more very shortly but
i think i think we should just move on
yeah all right so what you should be
seeing right now login it's an open
environment like this this is a
graciously provided by Google we got
some computer them to run some tutorials
so thanks Google we have five notebooks
here and we're going to be going through
them one by one so I'm going to hand
this off to David to handle the first
one is that big enough cool okay so I'm
not sure how many people are at all
familiar with tasks I'm assuming not
most but actually I'll do a quick show
of hands here how many people have
worked with tasks at all in the room
okay so mmm something like that I'm
really excited about this technology I'm
not one of the core developers jim is
and we have a variety of people at
continuum and outside the company who
are but as a way of expressing the
latent parallelism in your code that you
are maybe already working with for
scientific computation or data analysis
or something I
just think it provides some of the very
nicest easy-to-understand
abstractions around code that you may
have written that doesn't yet exposes
parallelism and the first lesson we're
going to go through is kind of some
fundamentals where we're understanding
what's going on at the heart of desk as
a both a desk is a portmanteau either of
distributed tasks or perhaps of DAG
directed acyclic graph tasks you can do
what you like with the actual name but
the idea is that it expresses the
dependencies in computation and then it
accompanied by a variety of execution
frameworks to actually resolve those
computations that need to be performed
so with this in a sense the lowest level
what we're going to look at at the
beginning is a part of desk called
delayed which simply lets us delay a
particular computation and then put it
into this graph of things that need to
happen so in this notebook let's look at
some very simple code I obviously this
is toy code and anything your rights
going to be more sophisticated than this
but here is a straightforward sequential
computation that we're doing we've
defined a couple functions which
arbitrarily take a little bit of time
you can imagine they take a little bit
of memory resource or something - we
could arrange that and then we do
something with those so we highlight
this one first we define our couple
functions these are regular toy Python
functions we run them and of course the
time taken is the time taken
sequentially by each of the operations
that has to be performed now let's take
that and use task two parallel eyes that
right now we're running on this
particular laptop which isn't a cluster
of machines and we'll talk about a
cluster machines and that's what we're
spinning up for you to have a cluster to
work with but this at least has a number
of cores on this machine I think eight
cores on this particular machine so we
can reexpress our same computation just
by wrapping things in this delayed call
so here's our same computation we have
above XY and z are defined by calling
some functions and then using those data
values of XY and z but rather than using
the simple functions we'll wrap those
functions in this call to delayed so
we're going to at some point take the
increment of the number one but we're
delaying actually doing that and
likewise for the other operations so
we'll define that and that happens
instantaneously in a couple microseconds
because no work has actually happened
here when we want to do the work we have
to call compute on whatever a particular
variable we've found a potential result
to so in this case we see that we've
computed it and it's managed to happen
in two seconds rather than in three
seconds not a huge speed-up but it's a
pretty simple computation one thing you
might notice I'm not sure if there's any
examples in this notebook or in the
others but you see what we're doing is
we're just taking some function wrapping
it in some transformation well that's
what you call a decorator and if we had
wanted to we could have written these
functions as decorators and then we
would automatically build in this so
perhaps we would have written our
functions in the first place that way
but we can also transform them later if
we want to or to give them a different
name and so on
since I'm holding a mic I have to do
one-handed typing so let's take a look
at what is that Z thing that we
calculated by calling Z compute that was
this delayed object this isn't any
concrete result it is something that
knows how to arrive at a result if you
decide to call compute on it
let's take a look more visually at
what's going on with that this is an
expression of the various computations
that need to happen so we need to do
some increment operations those would
become some results those would be added
those produce a final result this is a
very simple graph but we'll see much
more complex graphs later in this
tutorial
one thing that isn't right here right
now but I kind of like to show off is
there's actually I mean it could be some
weird complex hard to deal with data
structure that's maintaining this graph
but it's actually not it's just a almost
dictionary it was literally dictionary
and oh sorry that's Z okay it's this
slightly funny thing a shared dict
because we're going to deal with it in
multiple cores and so on but let's just
take a look at what it is as a regular
dict I have to type correctly with one
hand and you see that this is all the
computation is the picture is much
prettier but we just get some names
which in this case are based on uu IDs
that are associated with either
computations functions that may happen
or perhaps with data values and those
functions Jim is going to say that's too
much of a digression oh hello just real
quick turns out we had a lot more people
attending this tutorial
we expected so we are adding some more
nodes and in some point in the near
future the people that are still waiting
on getting a notebook should get one
that's all good and then we'll have more
resources even for users and people
that's great anyway so the question to
ask here I did a little bit of a
digression of showing you this
dictionary that's at the heart of it but
all we've done by calling delayed is
essentially build up this dictionary and
we can look at a pretty picture of it
one of the things about this is when you
build one of these complex graphs that
maybe have many nodes inside of it which
could in principle be computed you don't
necessarily have to compute the peak
node that depends on anything you can do
a simpler computation to get some
intermediate thing so here I could not
compute Z but I could compute X or Y and
there would be less work involved
because it didn't need to compute the
things that weren't required to get to
that point in the dag so let's look a
little bit more code that does slightly
more work it's still toy code we'll get
that before too long into some fairly
real examples as well but here we have a
collection of data it's just you know
sequence of numbers in this case and
maybe we want to do this thing where we
perform some computation on each of
those data points and then we do some
aggregation at the end this is already
probably looking a little like MapReduce
to people who are familiar with that
paradigm we keep this results as a list
we loop through the data we perform a
computation in this case just increment
but it's something with a sleep built-in
so it takes a little while and then we
add that result into the list and then
finally at the end of it we compute what
is the total of all these elements and
this one takes a little while it was
three seconds actually we're not doing
the sum as well but anyway so lines up
we have eight pieces of data it takes 8
seconds basically
and then the particular answer that
we're looking for is 44 I assume you can
mentally go through and increment each
of those numbers in deco summon that's
the answer you'll get but now I'd like
you to try writing this code in the
delayed fashion we saw just above
yourself I think that just if we take
five minutes people should be able to do
it it's a very similar pattern to what
we saw up here delaying this simple code
but we're going to transform the code in
my cell 13 into some deferred code in
this new cell of yours
yeah if it's not obvious to anybody the
person next to it may be obvious too
how many folks have come up with a
solution here enough that I'm going to
go ahead and show it in some of these
notebooks there's a little fold away
with this button that shows proposed
solutions to a variety of the things
that we do so I'm just going to copy
this into another cell to actually
execute it apparently a couple extra new
lines and so what we're seeing here is
this code looks a whole lot like the
stuff above we're still just looping
over but we're delaying doing each of
those increments and we're also delaying
as it happens doing the sum on the
things that we've accumulated into the
modified collection so initially this
total thing is this delayed object if we
put some additional timing in there we'd
see that it takes essentially zero time
to get to creation of that delayed
object and the only thing that took any
time at all was doing that compute step
and the compute step gets us the right
answer that 44 and it takes one second
to do it rather than the eight seconds
we saw previously because on this
machine I happen to have eight cores and
it's done
those operations the increment on you
know increment with the one-second sleep
on each of the eight cores
simultaneously so this you know these
eight characters are all I had to do to
transform my linear code my sequential
code into parallel code and I suppose
add the dot compute method on the thing
that I'm trying to get
let's do it a little bit with a little
more flow control than we had in that
simple example here's a couple more
functions they're also very simple one
of them were doubling a number the other
we're checking whether something is even
so this is what we're going to be using
for the conditional check we have our
data again and where's the sleep in here
the sleep is in the doubling but maybe
we want to do something slightly
different depending on some data value I
mean that's you know almost universal
programming paradigm so we're asking if
it's even then we're doing one kind of
operation otherwise we're doing a
different kind of operation and then
we're appending the various results and
this is going to take another eight
seconds I guess is it seems like it's
running longer than that we lost two
seconds why did we lose two um anyway
that's the time order that we're talking
about because the double and the
increment both had this one-second sleep
to simulate some operation that actually
took some time to do so now let's do the
same thing we did before but try to
transform this little bit of code into
something that is going to take
advantage of all of our cores using the
same tasks delayed mechanism and again
we'll just take five minutes to do that
so probably you want to start with
copying the code that was there before
because we're modifying in some
systematic fashion and what would be
tempting to do is something like this
let's put delayed around all the
functions that we've created so maybe we
want to delay that
and delay that and delay that so this is
the sort of initial naive report every
time you see the name of a function
let's delay it and let's try to run that
and we get a problem here
we have a type error we have to scroll
down a little while to get to the real
problem here but the idea here is that
if an object is delayed it doesn't have
a truth value
it's neither true nor false because it
hasn't evaluated to anything yet that
might be true or false so we have to
make a little bit of adjustment to that
completely simplistic approach namely
this thing that's the conditional we
really want to know the answer right
away with that so we're not doing a
deferred operation we're doing an
immediate operation to check for the
evenness of a given number and then it
runs fine
and that
although it really should have run fine
in much less time than that so what am I
doing wrong
well we haven't actually computed
anything here we've just called the me
interrupt that and try it again
yeah any insight Jim into what's wrong
with her cluster oh he stepped out he
did so this is not good for my example
but this is um I think kind of spin up
some nodes and they're all not doing
anything
what's that there's little reason to
actually that's one of the questions
that's posed just below since the sum
itself is going to definitely happen on
one core not distributed across cores
it's probably no reason to bother
delaying it but that should not be why
it's slow
is this working for anybody else there's
everyone else is sort of frozen as well
yeah let me see if I
you want to do it this question yeah um
let me answer the question see if you
can solve that I was going to pull it up
on your local just to show them you have
that status can I know where does online
that directory but yeah that's Experian
I'm sorry what's the question I
apologize good oh in delaying the list
comprehension or just why would the list
comprehension be much slower let's see
it's the delayed around the entire list
comprehension or its well so then it's
still one atomic operation that's being
delayed yeah I mean if you put the
delayed inside the comprehension then it
would create a comprehension of a whole
bunch of delayed objects and that would
then give the opportunities for
parallelism still frozen ish
yeah I'll give em a call do you want me
to pour locally yeah can you pull up
just a local copy so live demo apologize
for the glitch but Jim's just going to
pull up on his computer the local copy
of the same files and I'll demonstrate
what I'm talking about it so you can
only see it even though our cluster is
not behaving well
so at this point just follow along until
we get cluster behaving better but here
we've got is the font size still correct
or do I need to make it one bigger is
that does that look good for folks so
this is just running on the local
machine instead of on the cluster with
the problem but it's the same code here
we had done this purely sequential thing
and now we're paralyzing it but we're
being careful that the test that we need
to do needs to happen immediately and
then these various other actions with
their sleeps involved can be delayed and
when we run that we find that it takes
one second because we have to do at
least one of the operations with the
ones that can sleep in the middle of it
of course
what total is at this point is still one
of these deferred objects
it's not an actual number but how long
would it take then to compute the number
that's going to be two seconds so we're
saving a bit there one second to do the
evaluations of eight is even operations
and then two seconds and we can paralyze
the various doublings and increments and
taking a look at what that picture looks
like of the graph that we've created we
see something with a bit more
interesting parallel as a minute we'll
get to some ones assuming that are much
more complicated than this okay real
quick there so we had a lot more
participants than we expected and so we
had to start up soon more nodes and what
happened then was covered entities
rebalanced and killed everyone's
notebook session so if you can go back
to the initial page let's get that up
here again go back to that link just
close out everything you have right now
and click the blue button and log in
again and everything should just work
okay so I guess you're going to have to
just you know go through and run your
cells from the top again when that
happens right
you're getting a 404 interesting I am
not getting a 404 Oh
the local loan
has anyone gotten through the waiting
for your closer to start screen okay
cool it's just waiting for everyone else
I'll let you continue locally and at
some point you should respond back up so
some of you will be able to do the next
bits because you've spun up in some
won't but you okay so yeah I'm looking
at my local copy and I'm just going to
show you doing this on my local machine
which is you know one CPU with eight
virtual cores and we'll get some of the
parallelism here because I just want to
show you some of the code without having
too much more of a delay
by show of hands how people are back up
well most people can you take the UM
let's see that's the remote one okay
let's give that a try
okay
so in the notebook there's a few things
that it asks you to think about I think
I've mostly answered those but it says
why can't we use those delays for flood
control I believe the answer to that is
fairly straightforward because until
something's being been computed we can't
ask the question of whether it's a truth
e or a false issue so we're always going
to have to immediately do some
computation either by not wrapping it
and delayed in the first place or by
calling compute on that particular node
in the overall graph to get a result in
order to evaluate the branching
statement I showed you the example where
we actually did delay and we get that
exception where there's no truth value
associated with the delayed and one of
the people in the audience asked this
question about delaying some well it
works it's part it's this particular
node in our graph of computation but
since the sum is happening on one node
no matter what it's kind of indifferent
whether we actually bother delaying it
because it's going it's a global
operation with yeah let's do that so
let's not bother not bother delaying the
sum which will do as so
it's still a second to do the actual
computation here well I didn't really
show both pictures but what's that yeah
oh it's different in yours than what's
on screen here let's go back to that
during one of the exercises or break I'm
not quite sure why that is but this is
slightly simplified from the picture
before
you reassign some I don't think so
there yeah oh okay here's the different
one what oh yeah so here we are doing
we're sort of doing an incremental sum
in the graph as we get a couple results
to add together we go ahead and add them
together right away and so we get a kind
of deeper tree but I think that time was
still the same
so now we're going to do something with
some more real data using kind of the
same style but it's going to be more
than just you know adding and
multiplying a handful of numbers so the
first thing to do is run this cell that
has prepped data inside of it this is
just going to get some data into your
local node let's take a look at what's
in there what we have is a bunch of CSV
files and these are I'm not sure the
exact size of them that they're the
pretty large files
that's 22 megabytes each it looks like
so using just pandas um has everyone in
the room these pandas are at least
roughly familiar with it I am getting
enough a sense it too I'm not this is
not a tutorial about pandas but it's a
wonderful library for working with data
frame sort of tabular data with labelled
rows and columns and with that we can do
things like this we're reading in just
one of the files this 200 and whatever
megabyte file that's the 1990 data and
we can see that it has a fairly large
number of columns and it well the head
only has a few rows but there's a large
number of rows in the complete data set
we could ask about what kind of data it
is and we see that we've inferred that
some things are instants and things or
floats and a fewer objects just their
strings basically we might want to know
how many distinct airports are covered
here so this is the origin so it's
airplanes that are flying out of Newark
and LaGuardia and JFK that are in our
particular data set here and here
remembering we're just looking at one of
those ten years but as a plane panda's
operation we can group them together by
which airport they're coming from
looking at look at the departure delay
and take the mean of that and we get a
result pretty quick here in pandas where
there's these various delays I guess in
minutes from each of the airports on
average this canvas is great it works
wonderfully for a 200 megabyte file it
doesn't work so wonderfully for a
terabyte of data but tasks does
generalize to that terabyte of data
even say hundred gigabytes this is
probably not quite so much data that we
couldn't in principle do it in pandas on
one machine but it's a proxy for data
that was sufficiently big so here we're
looking at what those files are all the
things that end in CSV that are in that
particular data directory and as some
sequential code maybe we want to
aggregate the Psalms the counts loop
through the file names open each one of
them into a plain panda's data frame
group them together by where they
originate find out what the average
departure delay is within each of the
ten in this case files and then finally
do some computation at the end where we
get the same kind of thing we did before
but this is the cell that actually takes
a while to do we're opening up each of
the ten different panda's files doing
some grouping and aggregation within
each of them and eventually getting to
an answer which I probably should have
run in advance because I think this is
going to take about three minutes but
while it's thinking about it trust me in
another two minutes it's going to get to
the answer where it's going to show
something basically just like this it's
going to be a panda series that has as
rows the several airports but it's going
to be across all the years we'd like to
express that instead so basically it's
this code throwing in some delayed
operations where they are appropriate so
let's give that a try
now one of the things to keep in mind
before we do this exercise is we can
delay so in particular that we finally
got the answer that was definitely not a
wall clock time of four seconds
me and my cluster is being not happy
again I'm I'm going local again
a kick today out of it we're almost done
with this one let me just do the
explanation of this and then we'll take
a short break and try to get it worked
out by the next notebook so this is more
realistic on this one machine the
sequential code opening each of the
pandas files each of the CSV files into
a panda's data frame collecting some
intermediate aggregations than
aggregating the aggregations manually in
the sequential code is taking us this
six and a half seconds and we're getting
answers like this so we can paralyze
that we can delay pretty much anything
using this delayed operation so for
example maybe you were working with
numpy and you were creating a range of
numbers well you can delay that
operation but then when you have this
delayed thing like this X right here you
can do any of the operations that are
supported by that object type and those
in turn just make a more complicated
task graph but those are also delayed
operations so you're able to express the
same sorts of things that you're
accustomed to with numpy arrays or
pandas data frames or other kinds of
Python objects and it just happens that
behind the scenes there's a delayed
object there rather than a concrete
value so here Y is you know whatever it
is it's adding one element lies each of
the things in X and then taking some
slice out of it and then summing the
stuff from the slice and so this line of
code won't need to change whatsoever and
the you know subsequent 50 lines that do
various things that are indirectly
derived from the X ray won't have to
have any changes whatsoever just as long
as one of the inputs into it is one of
these delayed objects so you can do
something like this or delaying the
creation of the array then we're doing
some operation which actually results in
a why that's delayed we could call
compute as a method on the y
we can also call compute on several
objects at once and that will avoid
needing to duplicate computations that
are used in the graph of more than one
of the things that we're trying to get
the result for and in this particular
case that min max was those numbers and
this is that flight oh so it was the
thing that actually took six seconds
that was that this is the same thing
what I'm trying to show off here is
delaying this overall thing so let's
take a look at this solution here which
I'll just copy into a cell it's here's a
way that we might Express this whole
thing in the delayed way you can see it
in the solution cell
we might delay reading in the CSV file
for each of those we're still going to
do the group by which is going to take
some time but there's sort of nothing
that we get any gain from delaying there
but then oh yeah that's sorry that's
correct and then there's actually a
couple things we're interested in from
across the data frames both the sums and
the counts but there's some overlap in
the graphs of those and what we would
need to compute so rather than call some
stock compute and count stock compute we
do compute simultaneously across both
things and we can run this and it takes
no time basically
and see we have two seconds I guess that
is the mean our sorry the mean is
already realized as the dataframe
yeah so we already got the mean realized
at this point but we went from six and a
half seconds to two seconds because
we're paralyzing the several reads of
the different CSV files and then the
stuff downstream is relying on those
parallelized things let's take a look at
what the graph looks like for some of
that is that was that already in here I
guess it's not so like let's visualize
what goes into making the sums is this
SAMHSA's already concrete okay
Oh what sums is now it's already the
data frames sorry why is that the case
oh sorry we use the exact I use the
exact same name here let me bury it a
little so I retain the original names
I'll just call that sums two counts two
sometimes two accounts
so there's what I wanted to see why we
assigned that name somes in the initial
code but I could have used a different
name like somes - and you see that what
somes is is this list of different
delayed objects if we wanted to
visualize what's going on there we could
do well a couple things we could take
somes just the zero a thing and
visualize that and we see that that's a
pretty linear thing that's going on or
perhaps we would
visualize the whole lot I think this is
going to work exactly it's not okay I'm
not sure why I skip that bit but you can
see that each of these delayed is this
ad sequence of operations that have to
happen in this case they're purely
sequential and it's just really the sum
at the end that needs the aggregation I
think that's the stopping point for this
notebook and how what Jim take over but
I'm not sure what our status of our
compute nodes are so whether you want to
do the next bit on your local machine or
whether you want to you're still having
issues well I just switched to local
because I was I wanted to keep going
pack on the cluster that was local that
was local yeah
are you look like you're on the run
Ramon until the novices
cool seems to be back up show of hands
how many are having issues okay
did our people refreshing our people
were all right mean are you losing
connection to your notebook okay we
might want to do that let's see for now
let's have everyone shut down your link
and then go back to the blue button and
start over because later notebooks are
going to inquire the environment we have
set up here and hopefully all the kinks
will be interned out know so there's the
link again
say they are but later no books requires
a distributing the cluster that we have
set up I'm not sure what's going on
well in the interest of time I'm going
to move on and hopefully things will
work out I'll check back in in about 10
minutes or so and see if people are
having issues
so the first notebook we are talking
about using delayed to gain intuition
about building gas graphs so a desk is a
mix of a couple things desk includes
some schedulers for running graphs and
desk included some collections for
building graphs and graphs are the
intermediate language between the two
for representing parallel computations
so in the first bit we're using delayed
two off of these graphs manually we're
writing loopy code delaying some
function calls building up graphs and
then running them to make parallel
computations here we're going to use
desk data frames do the same thing so
that's data frame is a lot like canvas
feels like pandas same kind of methods
as pandas but behind the scenes it
builds up these graphs which are then
sent to the scheduler to be computed so
running the on the same data set that we
use for the last example here I'm going
to create a data frame using the read
CSV call desks read CSV is slightly
different than pandas instead of passing
in just a single file you can pass in a
glob so you can say data slash NYC
flight slash star dot CSV ants we grab
all the CSV s and treat them as one
giant data frame even they're made up of
different files so I'm going to run that
right now oh sorry
got to start with
since I restarted my environment I had
to reset the data if you restart and
didn't you don't have to run that again
to cool all right so now that it is
extracted this is not an actual pandas
dataframe we haven't actually read any
data from disk yet we haven't done
anything this just creates a graph
representation that shows how to build
that data frame if we decided to call
compute on it so right here we can see
we have the headers so all the different
net column types the departure delay
origin and then we have number of
partitions so we had 10 files each file
here is a different partition task is
just a collection of pandas dataframes
partitioned along the index we can call
ahead
pandas head method grabs the first five
rows so if we call that
yeah I might just go back to running
locally how we're going to do this yeah
we might do that so we're taking a quick
five-minute break here if people want to
stretch I'm going to get the link to the
github repo up there I think he
distributed notebooks I might just walk
through but in the interest of time this
is taking too long to figure out so hang
on
should cover there's just installation
there's just installation for there
Hey
everything keeps dying we're just going
to go to running locally and forget
about it so yeah I think people may have
been refreshing which would make sense
because it was you know we're having
issues so I'm just gonna go back to
running locally no worries yeah I don't
worry about it
it's things will work out cool
all right the link for the tutorial is
the links of the tutorial is here if you
download or go to that link you should
see in the readme instructions for
installing in the email - tutorial
presenters I was told everyone was
requested to have anaconda installed if
you have that set up you should be able
to con install the dependencies pretty
quick here and get set up I think just
because we're an hour into to our
tutorial I'm just going to press on but
we'll leave that link up for about a
minute or so
you
so the question was does desk provide
speed up if you run on a single machine
correct
yeah desk was originally written to work
just on a single machine the distributed
scheduler what came later so task was
originally written to work on out of
core datasets using your disk which can
hold a lot more data than your RAM has
everyone had a chance to take down this
link for the materials go I'm going to
just move on then I'm terribly sorry
about all the technical difficulties
here all right so running back to where
we were before so get the first five
rows after calling ahead so this is if
you remember this is a data frame this
is delayed object it has a graph backing
it saying how to actually compute the
data frame we haven't done anything
until we call methods the head method in
pandas gets the first five rows the head
method in desk gets the first five rows
and computes them so here we've actually
can see the first five rows of our data
set the tail method gets the last five
rows see what happens if you run that
and we get a big error and so this is
one of the caveats about using desk this
is such a common question that we
decided to cover it so desk read CSV
samples the first no certain number of
bytes from the first file and it tries
to infer all the data types from that so
all the d-type if it's an integer it's a
string and sometimes in your first let's
say thousand rows you might have a field
that is an integer the whole time and
then in thousand and one row it's
suddenly a float and if desk in first
the data types wrong it will air at
compute time so what happened here is
that in our initial call dass conferred
a couple of columns to have different D
types that they actually had so down
here we fixed that we specify the tail
numb is actually a string the first
couple rows it was just numbers
elapsed time as a float and we're also
going to specify that the canceled
column is a boolean and if we call tail
now this should work fine so computation
is deficit frame previously in the last
notebook we specified everything out
manually using delayed the Doucet frame
builds these parallel task graphs for
you without you having actually build
them yourself so you can write things
that look a lot like pandas code but
behind the scenes they build up these
parallel calls so here I'm going to call
a max on depth alas or going to the
maximum departure delay and then I'm
going to call dot compute on it this is
the same as the dot compute method on
delayed objects you're using before and
we can see that the maximum delay was
about 1,400 minutes which sounds awful
took about 6 seconds we can actually
visualize that graph queue you can see
it's just a big map operation ok how
many people are set up to run locally at
this point cool
so next we're moving on do some
exercises this is going to be if you're
familiar with the pandas API should be
fairly familiar it's a couple of
different questions about the data set
using the pandas API to answer them
well you are working on that will give
about five or so minutes that I'm going
to walk around and help people get set
up raise your hand if you need help
so the setup tasks for getting all of
your data extracted and everything set
up was only in the first notebook if
you're getting set up locally and
starting with notebook - that won't be
done you'll run into issues the command
you need to run is this so just add that
tone of your cells and run it before you
do everything else
yeah
No
Oh
which
you
all right I'm going to start walking
through the solutions to these sounds
like most people have had a chance to at
least try some of them alright so
actually not even walking through all of
them how many rows are in a data set you
can just call length on data frame
networks length calls compute internally
so you don't even have to call compute
on it
- supports filtering so normal normal
normal panas operations like filtering
on the truth of a column work fine group
by operations work you can just use the
group by method at the end of this know
we have to call compute this is the same
as you have it delayed before you
actually have to explicitly say when to
compute something except for couple
methods which will implicitly compute
average Department urged upon or delay
just another group operation grouping on
origin taking the mean of departure
delay and calling compute worst average
departure delay data week
another group operation sharing and
immediate results so as we mentioned in
the previous notebook just in passing if
you have multiple different data objects
you want to compute and they share the
same underlying graph it can be more
efficient to compute them all at once
so here we create non cancelled which is
just all of the non canceled flights and
then we take the mean of the departure
delay and then we take the standard
deviation the departure delay so these
are two desk objects and you want to get
both of them but underlying it they're
going to have to both read from disks
gonna have to both do the filtering
operation so if we call compute twice
once on mean delay and once on the
standard deviation is delay it's going
to have to do the reading from disk
twice stamp through the filtering twice
it's going to do all of those twice but
the Dow's compute method instead will
merge the two graphs and do them only
once so this should take about half the
time
about 17 seconds or seven seconds on my
computer yep
using the dies method you can actually
see what the merged graph looks like so
here we can see all of the reading from
CSV operations and all of the individual
things and then at the very top we have
the difference between computing the
mean computing the standard deviation so
often if you have multiple things that
you would like to compute you can just
use Daffy Duck compute instead of
calling the compute method on the object
yeah yeah so he mentions sometimes these
graphs can get large actually sometimes
it's not even a graph is the underlying
library that draws these will bog down
if a graph is too big but for larger
graphs it can be nice to specify the
file name so you can just say file name
equals something and pass it to a file
and then open it you know as a PNG or
something all right
so our data set right now stores
timestamps as integers if we actually
look at the CRS depth time column just
taking the first ten rows you can see
this is supposed to be a three forty but
it's stored as an integer
we'd like to convert that actually to a
pandas date time object so we can work
with it you know it's a time series so
to convert these timestamps of scheduled
departure time we need to convert them
to time built objects in pandas and then
we can add them to the date column that
we already have
unfortunately des doesn't already have
the to time Delta function we're going
to need to build this ourselves
so in pandas we do it this way we get
the date for the same above row so I'm
going to call head on that just to pull
those out and then we would take and
we'd slice off the hours bit from
integer and convert that to a time Delta
we slice off the minutes bit from
integers and we paired those to a time
Delta and then we just offset the date
by the hours and minutes of each row and
so you can see right here the date and
time for all the flights that we had for
that ten row sample
so as I said - doesn't currently
implement this method this hasn't been
added but we have provided a lot of
escape hatches for adding in custom code
that you might want to run yourself so
for things that either aren't in the
pandas API or our pandas API methods we
haven't added already so in this case
we're going to use map partitions you
can look at the docs right here so map
partitions is a method on the data frame
objects it takes in a function and some
arguments you can pass in arguments or
keyword arguments after so in this case
we're going to convert that pandas code
we wrote above to run with the data
frame instead so here we're slicing off
the hours this is a desk object and then
we're going to call map partitions on it
pass in pandas to time Delta with the
unit hours and we can do the same down
here for the minutes with the unit
minutes and then we're going to add the
offsets here running this this is still
just a dowsing series we build up a
graph behind it expressing how to do
this computation so if we were to add to
time Delta to death this is exactly how
we did implement it using map partitions
and then you can look at the first five
rows of our data frame and see that yes
indeed they were continued to converted
to date night objects so now we're going
to exercise we'd like you to rewrite the
above to use a single call to map
partitions instead of two so currently
we're creating these desc objects
calling mount partitions on them and
eventually creating a departure
timestamp this creates a lot of extra
tasks in the graph it'll be more
efficient to only call this once so if
you can rewrite the above to be just a
single function call map partitions on
at once to get the output I'll give you
about five minutes or so to do that
crash
all right show of hands has anyone
figured this one out would anyone like
more time or should we just move on I
think we're going to move on so looking
at the solution we have we've taken the
code we had above in pandas right here
and it's pretty much just copy pasted
down into a function so we just create
on the individual data frame which at
this point map partitions when the
function actually gets called that'll be
a panda's data frame object it gets and
then we pull off the hour's time Delta
minutes minutes time Delta and add the
offset just as before all right so
moving on to notebook three we're gonna
be talking about schedulers so so far
we've just been building graphs and then
running them without really talking
about what actually does the running so
desk provides a couple different
schedulers for running these tasks
graphs we have the threaded scheduler
which is what you've been using so far
it takes the graph and runs it in a
thread pool we have a multi processing
scheduler which does the same thing but
doesn't in a process pool and then there
is a synchronous scheduler which just
runs everything in the main thread and
there's benefits of using each one there
is also a distributed scheduler which
we'll talk about in a bit after that so
as I said we have multiple schedulers
threaded multi processing tasks get is
the serial synchronous scheduler which
is really useful for debugging you can
specify which scheduler to use different
collections have different default
schedulers to use but you can specify
which one you want to use explicitly by
either passing in the get keyword to the
call to the compute method or to the
compute function you can also set things
locally or globally using Dowsett
options so here we've wrapped this call
to compute in a context manager
specifying the multi processing
scheduler and so that's going to use
multi processing or you can just set it
globally to always use it so I'm going
to import a couple things create the
same data frame that we did in the past
one this is a desk data frame we'll
create an example computation figuring
out the largest departure delay and then
we'll call compute using first threads
just took about seven seconds I'm going
to yeah yeah just for time I'm going to
skip the call to multi processing that
one takes a lot longer I'm going to talk
about that in a sec and then the single
thread so the multi processing scheduler
is fairly inefficient for common for
data frame problems and the reason for
that is it's written in a way that
requires all data to be serialized back
to the main process after all computes
so it works really well for a different
collection called desk bag but not so
well for data frame and the going advice
is to instead of using multi processing
to use the distributed scheduler instead
locally which I'll be showing in a
second anyway if we look at this we see
that we had seven seconds for threads
and made about ten seconds for serial so
we didn't really get much parallelism
there we would expect on my computer
which has eight different cores to get a
maximum speed-up of about eight right
this is a pretty parallel operation
we're reading from a bunch of different
files doing things serially on them and
it's some endpoint doing a reduction
this is pretty pair Eliza bowl
has anyone or does anyone know why we
might not be getting parallels or using
threads
it is yeah they go the global
interpreter lock so Python has this
thing called a global interpreter lock
which means that normal Python code can
only be run in one thread at a time
certain libraries like numpy might
release the interpreter lock which means
that you can actually achieve true
parallelism with threads in this case
the bottleneck operation is the call to
read CSV which is working with a lot of
Python objects and so can't really be
paralyzed so these are the kind of cases
where you might want to use the multi
processing scheduler or the distributed
scheduler I'm going to skip this because
we're running short on time distributed
scheduler so we have another scheduler
called the distributed scheduler it
lives in a separate library called
distributed you can create it in a
couple different ways you can
automatically have it set up a cluster
by just importing clients and creating
one or you can manually set up a cluster
I'm going to skip right to running
locally and then we'll show manually in
a second so from here we import client
from dowsed asserted and i create one
cool so right here we have a distributed
client this is the address of the
scheduler it has eight processes and
it's running on eight course by default
this will create the same number of
workers as I have course as I showed
above I have a course on this machine so
I have eight workers before I run this
we're just going to open up
well the distributed scheduler also has
some really nice Diagnostics so this is
not in your notebook because this was
all set up to run on the environment
that didn't end up working but if you go
to localhost colon
87 87 slash status you should be able to
pull up the Diagnostics page yourself
anyway I'm going to call compute on the
same computation we had before remember
that this took seven seconds using
threads about 10 seconds running
serially and if we watch the Status page
we can actually see what's going on over
here
so each of these rectangles is a task so
this is a call to reading panda's read
CSV some getitem calls if we zoom in we
can see actually computing the max is
very very small component of that most
of our time is spent reading from disk
but going back here we see we actually
achieved some true pal ISM here
this took 4 seconds here which is a
little bit less than half of what it
took to run serially so one nice thing
about using the distributed scheduler is
when you create a client it's
automatically set globally so I don't
actually even need to pass in get I can
just call dot compute and that's going
to run distributed C so we can also
setup a distributed cluster instead of
having one I'm up and setup instead of
using actual distribute I'm mission to
set up a local cluster on my machine
just to demonstrate
okay so we have a couple different tools
for doing these automatically if you use
ec2 there's a tool called - DC - we have
ones for setting up things using
kubernetes marathon there's about us if
you have a common cluster manager
there's usually one that we have they
will work with it if you want to set
things up manually I'm going to
demonstrate that right now it's fairly
simple
we need a command line the command task
scheduler this is hard to do with one
hand so you create a scheduler -
printouts and stuff one of the things is
the scheduler address and then we create
some workers with the desk - worker
command one of these you pass in is that
same scheduler address
Segan doubt staff scheduler and - worker
yeah they come in when you have
distributed they should just adamant
within your path if you're not in the
same Python environment you might be
having issues with that just distributed
and if you follow the install
instructions in the repo you should have
it anyway one of these pass in is just
the scheduler address and this creates
worker so if you have multiple different
nodes calling - - worker on each node
should have the same effect and then to
create the client you just pass in the
same scheduler address to client so we
can see that this is by default worker
called worker creates a single process
with as many threads as you have course
so in this case I connected to the
scheduler setup on the command line
which has one worker process with eight
threads and then we can actually you
know compete on that one - OH
none of this applies anymore because
we're not actually running to shoot it
um can i what can I do we can talk about
the Diagnostics let me quick create some
long-running computation hang on
okay so if you're running locally skip a
little bit where we talk about using a
distributed scheduler so the one cell
that I had edited before this whole bit
and we can just move down and everything
should just work so skipping the what
happened here all of that just going to
diagnostics so I have right here the
Diagnostics page and for the local
schedule that I've created and I'm going
to call largest laid out compute and we
can look at it so a couple different
things in here um just really
frustrating
cool all right so looking at these plots
the top one right here is the number of
bytes stored on that worker so after
everything around you can see it cleared
back down to zero the worker has no
nothing in memory at that time over on
the right you can see the task
processing this plot right here is a
task stream each rectangle represents a
single task they're color-coded so all
of these yellow ones are all pandas read
text and then down on here this is a
time and progress which won't release
see if we run that again if we can catch
it you can see progress bars for you to
the different tasks so walking through
time is going to pick one of these group
by computation here so group by origin
figuring out the mean departure delay
can go back over and look at the
different operations again pandas read
text which is reading from reading a CSV
from disk takes most of the time
to set that up to run a couple times so
we can talk about the different blots up
here you can see we have all the
intermediates stored in memory they get
cleared out every time different tasks
processing progress bars for all the
different tasks this is really useful
for debugging and figuring out
bottlenecks I'm actually giving a talk
on this tomorrow on all the different
things you can learn from watching these
plots all right
so that's life just to conclude this one
Rick we the the main point of this
notebook here is to show that we have
different collections that create
different bass graphs and then they can
be run on different schedulers you can
swap in schedulers after you've written
your code you can write code to run
locally using threads or processes and
then swap out a distributed scheduler
and run distributed I'm going to skip
notebook 4 because that's intended to be
run completely deserted which we can't
do because technical difficulties and
we'll just go right to the desk
ecosystem notebook and then at the end
we'll have some time for questions so so
far we've just been talking about
desolated app data frame but desk is a
lot larger than just those two so we're
going to go through a couple different
projects that might be of interest to
you quick talk about them and then
provide some links so dasker a is
another core collection found inside the
desk library we have data to frame which
looks a lot like pandas - gray looks a
lot like numpy it mirrors most of the
common numpy interface so we have
reductions you funks you can do indexing
operations we implement some of the
linear algebra module and some of the
fourier transform' module and a bunch
other stuff this was the first stats
collection this was the one that task
was originally thought to be just a
parallel array library and it kind of
expanded from that so it's up the most
battle-tested so here we're going create
a random tasks array actually yeah
creating a random access ray the DA
namespace - gray looks a lot like the
numpy namespace has a lot of the same
things you'd expect so creating a normal
one one thing we specify that we
wouldn't specify for numpy is a call to
chunks so like data frames are split in
different partitions along the index
dasker A's are split into different
chunks along different axes so here we
have a square 2d array 10,000 by 10,000
split in two
chunks that are five thousand by five
thousand this is going to be four
different jumps we can perform matrix
multiplication compute the mean of that
if you look at the graph that that built
up because again this is a lazy
collection so like Gauss airframes we
haven't done any computation yet we just
built up a graph it's a lot more
complicated than the one for a dataframe
arrays in general the graph circles are
more complicated and then we actually
call compute on that and you'll get your
answer for more information on that you
can go to the desk or a Docs which are
linked right here again the docs page is
a good place to start for most of this
yeah so we got our answer their desk bag
is another collection if you're familiar
with spark a desk bag might feel the
most familiar to you it implements a
general paralyze abul collection you can
have any kind of Python object inside it
you don't need just not necessarily
working with just arrays or data frames
so it feels a lot like a PI spark RDD
influence methods like map filter fold
group by whatever here we're going to be
loading some data JSON data this is a
common use for working with that bag is
working with unstructured data such as
JSON so I have
I have right here a directory of same as
the flight data before JSON and we can
read it in using desk bag read text this
is going to splitting the line dinted
line delimited JSON into multiple
partitions you can take the first row to
actually see what it looks like it's a
string so single line from line
delimited JSON and then you can do
things like maps we can map a JSON that
loads across all the rows pull out the
columns we actually care about and then
you can convert it to a data frame so a
lot of the data collections play well
together this is a common use of bag is
to do some pre-processing operations
then you might want to convert it to a
different collection that might be more
efficient pandas in general can be more
efficient than working with general
Python objects so here we can see we've
converted our desk bag into an actual
data frame or desk a different object
and we can take the first five rows as I
mentioned before we have several
different tools for setting up clusters
since they're doing things manually or
something up a local cluster you can
also use one of these tasks easy to is
one for spinning up clusters on ec2 with
a single command line command
that's kubernetes same thing for
kubernetes we have once per yarn
marathon anyway Doc's are all linked
here if you wanted to check that out
later recently we've been working on
some work with machine learning there's
a couple different ways to use desk with
machine learning workflows one of them
is to use the dowsed distributed job Lib
back-end which is a recent addition to
how job looks you can just import desks
or to shoot a job Lib and then specify
the parallel back end with the parallel
back end context manager and then the
normal psychic learn code makes it
slightly smaller we'll be paralyzed
internally there's a couple caveats
about this one is that lots of the
scikit-learn estimators currently
specify which back in these you can't
override them with a different back end
work is being done right now to fix that
and this really is only efficient for
that refer work where the compute to
data size ratio is high so where the
data you might be serializing to your
different workers is small but the work
you're going to be doing on it is large
enough that the time sent spent to
serialize it is worth it
but in general this is a nice way to
paralyze computations the demo we always
use for this is using grid search where
your serializing some small rays but you
might be doing lots of different fits on
them and that seems to paralyze fairly
well another one that is implanted a is
def search cv this is a directed ask
implementation of socket learns grid
search cv and randomized search cv
classes they're just drop ins you just
change your import and everything should
just work for certain workflows these
can be more efficient because we can
find repeated computations so for
example if you have a pipeline with
multiple steps and you're going to be
fitting across each different step we
can avoid refitting step a for every
single call to fit for the pipeline in
general a couple other ones that I don't
have examples for - PLM is a new library
implementing generalized linear models
using desc
so if you're used to doing logistic
regression this is data implemented one
works with dots gray you can fit
generalized linear models across a
cluster using that desk extra boost and
dowse tensorflow are libraries for
setting up and working with extra boost
and tension flow respectively across the
cluster and then there are several
libraries in the larger PI to the
ecosystem that used asked under the
covers
so x-ray is one you might be familiar
with is created originally for working
with climate data science or climate
science sets but in general it's just a
labeled and D array library can actually
used F to work on large out of core and
parallel computations so I could image
uses to ask behind the scenes to
paralyse image filtering operations
optionally recently airflow added adapts
distributed backend so you can run your
airflow workflows using gaseous tributed
to go
browser cluster and data shader is a new
plotting library that uses desktop
tional e parallels it's good - anyway I
apologize for technical difficulties if
you want to find me or David afterwards
for one-on-one questions but we also
have about 10 minutes or so right now
for questions here yes actually
so the question was can you compare and
contrast desk and spark haha so this is
such a common question there's a slide
for it so - can spark are fairly similar
they are intended to do similar things
spark is great for ETL and database
operations it's got a sequel interface -
tis not a sequel interface task is
intended to mirror more of the common
Python interfaces so like pandas spark
is pretty fast plays well with the
existing a dupe Seco system desk is
great in that we wrote it to feel a lot
more like the Python ecosystem so it
feels more like numpy pandas
scikit-learn it's better for ad-hoc
parallelism so spark you chain a bunch
of fixed operators together a MapReduce
fulbe group by desk you can generate
arbitrary tasks graphs and then run them
so it's a lot well we find it's nicer to
work with for the flexible complicated
workflows you might have in certain
science applications task is sometimes
easier for people familiar with Python
it's easier to set up maybe and it plays
well with the existing sci-fi ecosystem
I'm not gonna add just a tiny bit to
that the benchmark stuff that I've seen
certainly spark and you know through PI
spark and desk fulfills somewhat of a
same kind of ecological role generally
desk
tends to do better on
Eric distribution are you going to I
don't want to say that they're both good
at different things
well I sparked us better at more text
processing things are you know so -
screaming that now I I just stay away
from Mitch Bergsma Jenna okay they're
both good at different things
other questions not sure I understand in
the distributed plaster comment here on
the note he said you have distributed
cluster already set up on your machines
so that was for the environment that did
not end up working out there was a
distributed cluster that was set up for
all of you to be using and then
everything failed miserably so it
doesn't relate to viewer King locally on
your laptop so my question is that say I
just open a c2w sec to our sincere
Microsoft Azure cloud and then I take
all this code and can run into what they
are so I believe the question is how
would you set it up on ec2 or Azure so
for et tu we have the desk et tu command
line operation is one-liner set up a
desk enabled cluster with ec2 for Azure
I'm not familiar with Azure so I can't
say how but in general if you can run
the desk scheduler command in one
machine and the desk were commanded a
different machine you can set up a
cluster yourself we have a couple tools
to make this easy for certain systems
you might want to set it up on yeah is
any plan to also miss some of the
parallelism algorithm we did that so
that we don't have to manually I mean
it's not possible for all the cases but
in many cases I see the way she's like
it's possible to do that automatically
so do you have a plan to introduce that
in I believe the question is is there a
plan to automate the parallel algorithms
so for the common collections a data
frame looking like pandas - gray looking
like numpy
most of the common methods and functions
you'd want to use are already
implemented there's a handful that we've
missed usually that's an oversight on
our part we've tried to implement
everything that's easy and several other
things that are hard some things don't
parallel as well and we might have
skipped those intentionally we don't
want people writing code that does work
but does end up being very inefficient
but in general if you're doing things
that fit the common interfaces of numpy
and pandas what you're trying to do is
probably already implemented and then we
have things like das delayed and a
couple escape hatch methods for data
frame and das gray to allow you to
paralyze your own existing code which
might not fit one of the library
interfaces that are exist next question
yeah I was going to ask a similar
question just do you imagine on the
roadmap that desk would be kind of a
back-end that pandas would use or are
they incompatible there's I I'm not sure
if you're aware that there's a West and
some of the pandas team have been
working on pandas to design docks and
that's one of the open issues is to have
desk maybe behind the scenes in pandas
so how does desk work with things like
Luigi or celery in terms of the is I
believe the question is how does that
compare to them so doc is not a back-end
for Luigi or celery we can't be used
behind the scenes for that you could use
desk as a step in something like Luigi
or celery to do some of your processing
or you could write a pipeline like you
might implement in those using something
like gas delayed
so you're saying that there's
possibility for pandas to for a desk to
be behind the scenes so maybe I mean
it's everything is in planning stage
right now I can't say yes or no sure
something like that were to order to
take effect how would that affect some
of the other libraries that are built on
top end is like these stats models for
example right I mean would you still be
able to breathe I mean for example I
have no idea this is all future work I
will say since you mentioned stats
models there's some awesome work done by
a google Summer of Code student last
year that recently allows paralyzing
stats models behind the scenes and
because they use job wood for that you
can then use tasks to paralyze stats
models behind the scenes 3 it's cool fix
i guess 'sir words like the largest kind
of a commercial kind of a cluster of
tasks that's known to be operating
second what like the largest cluster of
our distributed like how many nodes only
planning a commercial type of
application I'm not sure if I can say
exactly we've benchmarked with hundreds
and hundreds of nodes I think at one
point we have a thousand dead cluster up
for benchmarking I'd say that there are
there definitely commercial and academic
institutions running clusters in the
hundreds of notes using tasks right now
do you know if desk works with data
frames or libraries and leverage data
frames like geo pandas on top of pandas
it's it's funny you mentioned Jia pandas
there's some ongoing work right now like
I got pinged on it today
paralyzing Jia pandas with desk so
currently no future yes
maybe another question about the
supported backends are you supporting
the classic HPC systems like slow and
torque where you have to specify
wartimes
memory requirements for each of the
drops or would it require some tinkering
from the user side all of these are
things we would like to do the question
is you know who has expertise who has
time to work on these things I believe
in the desc distributed repo right now
on github there's an issue about how do
we interact with slurm properly so say
any more anyone else okay
in the for I apologize again for the
environment not working properly hearing
all the technical difficulties you have
the link to this tutorial for our larger
and more in-depth tutorial there's in
the doubts Creepo we pull this up right
now there is or the doubts korg there is
a repo called bass tutorial which is
intended to be downloaded and run
locally walkthrough on your own time so
that's right here if you want to
download that and we're counting on your
own time you could do that here
otherwise I will myself and David rhew
be around for the next couple days if
you don't ask questions as always we
have Doc's online and a github repo if
you have issues thank you